bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte fort vous avez entendu
ce témoignage dans un pays de plus d'un
milliard d'habitants
on voit que c'est difficile et c'est
évident de faire respecter les gestes
barrières les restrictions sanitaires
comment là on peut sortir de cette
situation à votre avis ils sont un
niveau de tension des systèmes
hospitaliers qui rend l'esprit difficile
notre interview a été très riche en
informations notamment le fait qu'ils
n'ont pas suffisamment de postes
d'oxygène par exemple pour les géants
comme ont besoin donc c'est difficile
avec autant de distance de savoir
comment ils pourront s'en sortir mais
risque d'y avoir beaucoup de dégâts
alors justement le pays bénéficie
désormais d'une aide internationale
inédite depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire c'est la première d'une telle
ampleur depuis le début de la pandémie
mais est-ce que ce sera suffisant 6
millions de cas au mois d'avril plus de
200000 morts selon des chiffres
officiels ce serait bien plus que juste
espérer que l'aide internationale et
puis la riposte locale parce que le
médecin qui arrivent et disent eh bien
quand même en inde et une grande
capacité de production de médicaments de
vaccins ils ont des médecins qui sont de
grande valeur en général donc tout ça
permettra de limiter un peu la casse
mais on sent bien la tension qui
actuellement dans les grandes villes
comme new delhi ou bombay que ça va sans
doute se chiffrer à beaucoup plus que
les régions concernant la
d'international l'aide internationale
elle vient des pays de puissance de
grande puissance qui gère même parfois
difficilement à cette crise sanitaire
par exemple en france
la france peut faire parvenir du
matériel de soins alors que les
soignants ici se plaignent du manque de
moyens et de ressources 1 il est
important de toujours essayer de
raisonner avec de la solidarité c'est à
dire c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas tous les
moyens dont on aurait besoin mais on est
quand même
actuellement sans difficulté pour ce qui
est des postes d'oxygène par exemple
pour ce qui est du matériel de
protection donc si on peut faire un peu
de solidarité et trans et les choses
dont on a pas besoin immédiatement
maintenant je crois qu'il faut le faire
il faut pas se dire après il ya quelques
mois on marque nike pour battre les
roues de voiture depuis jamais avoir de
paix mais là on se retrouve dans cette
situation il ya ce variant indiens aussi
qui est inquiétant qui inquiète beaucoup
les pays européens
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur ce variant
indien alors on n'en sait pas beaucoup
bah pas grand chose actuellement elle se
mariant indien il est préoccupant parce
qu'il a deux mutations qui sont toutes
les deux associés a probablement une
plus grande transmission n'est par
contre l'exemple de new delhi une des
vitres le plus avec l'épidémie
actuellement il est pas du tout dominant
là-bas d'épidémie à new delhi
actuellement est surtout liée aux
variants britannique
donc on fait un peu un raccourci on
découvre a varié en inde et puis la
situation en inde est catastrophique
mais on n'est pas sûr que les deux
soient vraiment l'idée qu'il faut
surveiller il faut mieux étudier de ce
pavillon indien mais il n'est pas du
tout dominant d'un dollar lundi à paris
la vaccination justement 150 millions de
personnes ont été vaccinées
est-ce que l'inde peut aller au bout
justement de cette campagne de
vaccination aujourd'hui il faut des il
faut des fois des vaccins ils peuvent
aller au bout et on vaccine toute la
population indienne est vacciné contre
diphtérie tétanos donc c'est quelque
chose qu'ils peuvent faire maintenant
c'est une question de délai et c'est
vrai que 150 millions ça fait moins de
10% de la population donc c'est pas du
tout suffisant pouvoir même atténuée il
épidémies telles que celles qui vivent
actuellement il faut arriver à 50 %
d'une population vaccinée pour avoir
vraiment un bel impact et les
traitements aussi un grand nombre
d'indiens utilisent leur md et vire pour
se soigner
voilà ça n'a rien changé probablement
parce que les infos qu'on a sur
l'efficacité du rem désir c'est vraiment
limité s'il y en a vraiment une c'est
pure commandé par exemple par l'om est
surveillé et je suis pas mal d'études
avec beaucoup de monde beaucoup ne sera
pas une solution aurait le désirent sur
le long le moyen terme a vu là un
système de santé très fragile de ce pays
à quoi il faut s'attendre
il faut s'attendre a probablement un
mois de mai là qui va être très
difficile parce que les hôpitaux sont
déjà saturés alors qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de gens qui cherchent à arrivée
à l'hôpital
et puis après il va se passer ce qui
s'est passé dans d'autres pays ce que
l'épidémie va finir par diminuer un peu
en partie parce qu'ils auront vacciner
plus de membres d'un parti parce qu'il y
aura la protection un peu naturel les
gens qui auront récupéré de leur corps
vide donc toutes les vagues jusqu'ici
ont fini par descendre
donc ça peut finir par des cendres de
savoir jusqu'où et va monter combien de
temps et va durer
c'est vraiment difficile à dire merci
beaucoup à vous pierre tattevin
infectiologues chef du service des
maladies infectieuses au chu de rennes